28 441 Dy Lane [__] n you know this [__]
ain't about nothing [__] don't play dumb
[__] yeah real talk [__] my man's
people ran off on me got me looking for
him the ray van riding I can't lie I'm
paranoid this periph in the car with a
little boy I'm going all the way and I
ain't leaving till I'm done work the
night shift without a gun I'm going to
pray for you it's just me and Boogie we
still out of state Thug I'm trying to
rape the budget sent the invo to the
plug I got gray white and 10 I'm
thinking [__] I
my hands in it if they come they come
[__] py ass [__] ain't no been
watching sneaky [__] trying to play me
close my [__] [__] I be creeping but I
[__] them then I go it's that life on
the road 30 days in the van no help get
it gone [__] [__] up my plans like
should I Ser my fans but should a [__]
chill rap game Dope Game what's the
fastest to a meal I can't see myself
getting caught up with these [__] so
I'm straight some [__] make it happen
some [__] in way I got it on me out in
traffic let me know I get you straight
122 breakdown turkey bags for the weight
[__] [__] with me how you do
that oo you got for me God damn what you
do with this one don't play dumb [__]
okay don't play dumb [__] hey come on
I'm rich likey I get pissed off for real
2500 that get a [__] kill No Cap ain't
going to see me doing [__] but getting
rich my [__] 50 stay shorty I got two I
can't to get all of this money nothing
else I got 10 bad [__] I put on the
sh when I get two 50 of G but [__] I'm
pass that if you ain't got a dollar took
you'll get last that little ass boy to a
big dog like me make him do the right
thing like Spike Elite 30 for a whole
thing yep this a white t 05 black T So
ice White House recers get indicted then
fight take him to the D get hot like a
lighter turn to mgy when I'm over this
sto maybe I'm the one that's damage do a
bad [__] front those service every gam
getting so seat belt stra cuz I'm ride
through the O it get Wicked tricky and
whiskey all that I was count dog [__] I
forgot to call back where that dog at
where the lean where the pills I've been
pulling big moves me nutty and Dr Bill
I'm about to drop my nuts give a [__]
how they feel made 300,000 [__] got real
now I'm iest shopping I Want It All no
budget X on the bricks this a offwhite p
since 064 I've been hustling [__] even
though white people [__] with us I'm
going go [__] anything I touch no I
kill it 50 state shorty probably got
your ho with me you know
time get a bag shootter back and forth
like tennis five a.m on the wake up side
lame ass [__] hit the booth and make
up lies [__] only make shots in the
layup line and you can't find [__]
when it's game time KN deep in the mix
I've been like that since the kid before
I met face my tatted on my wrist before
I had paper I was laying [__] down
spell a [__] on you Kim coming out the
top side than the fiend coming out give
me cop Vibes J re coming out F five sh
he can't breathe in one thing I need
from a [__] is mouth and throat I'mma
sell out then cop some more we don't do
[__] but stand on that business for sure
had no work with standing in the kitchen
with ho wishing for a plug or something
like front door service now [__]
overnight it good runs never last long
so don't get
it I a let [__] score man I'm still
playing D 30 for a whole thing [__]
this a white t no for
real whole thing [__] this a white t
keep all the [__] ups keep it let's do
it 441 d l [__] [__] shout out to my
[__] Bo K you know what the [__] going
on [__] for life [__] hey you just
watch another freestyle brought to you
by the good Folks at LRG God damn it
shout out to LRG all right go use the
promo code bootleg right now on their
website l-r-g.com say 40% off at
checkout 40% off at checkout use that
promo code and we got another freestyle
coming ASAP